[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اعترفت
10 14 دوله تشارك في اجتماع مجموعه اصدقاء
سوريا في مراكش بالائتلاف الوطني السوري
المعارض ممثلا وحيدا للشعب
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
السوري
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لكي نناقشه في عنوانين
رئيسين ماذا سيترتب على دفعه الاعتراف هذه
لا سما الاعتراف الامريكي ولماذا اذا
يستمر تلكؤ المجتمع الدولي في تسليح
[موسيقى]
المعارضه رغم الاعتراف الدولي الواسع
بالائتلاف السوري المعارض في اجتماع
اصدقاء سوريا في مراكش كممثل شرعي للشعب
السوري الا ان مساله تسليح مقاتلي الثوره
بقيت في دائره الرفض حاليا على الاقل
واقتصر اجماع
114 دوله شاركت في هذا الاجتماع على ضروره
تقديم المساعده الانسانيه العاجله
للسوريين في الداخل وللاجئين منهم في دول
الجوار فهل سيشكل هذا الاعتراف علامه
فارقه في مسار الثوره
السوريه دفعه تاييد قويه تلقاها الائتلاف
الوطني السوري المعارض خلال مؤتمر مجموعه
اصدقاء سوريا المنعقد في مراكش الدعم الذي
اعتبره الائتلاف معنويا اكثر منه عمليا
تمثل في اعتراف نحو 114 دوله به كممثل
شرعي للشعب السوري هذه المسانده بدت
استجابه مباشره لمطالب الائتلاف الذي اكد
ضروره الانتقال الى مرحله الدعم بالافعال
مطالبنا هي الاعتراف بحق الشعب السوري في
الدفاع عن نفسه بكافه الوسائل الممكنه
اننا نحمل المجتمع الدولي وخصوصا روسيا
كامل المسؤوليه في حال استخدم النظام
الاسلحه الكيميائيه ضد شعبنا كلام الخطيب
عززه موقف اللجنه العربيه الخاصه بمتابعه
الوضع في سوريا التي تراسها قطر قد اثبت
الاتلاف الوطني انه بالفعل ممثلا حقيقي
وشرعي للشعب السوري وانه البديل الشرعي
للنظام الحالي وانه المؤتمن على استلام
السلطه وعلى اداره الفتره الانتقال
ولذلك فان المطلوب الان وبحا دعم هذا
الاتلاف ماديا ومعنويا والاعتراف به وكانت
واشنطن قد استبقت افتتاح مؤتمر مراكش
باعلانها الاعتراف بتمثيل الائتلاف لكل
السوريين مما يحمل رساله قطيعه النهائيه
مع نظام الاسد بعد فتره من التاني وربما
اعمال
الحسابات قررنا الاعتراف بائتلاف المعارضه
ممثلا وحيدا للشعب السوري بعد ان اصبح هذا
الائتلاف يعكس تنوع الشعب هناك نعتبرهم
اليوم الممثله الشرعيه للشعب السوري في
مقابل نظام الاسد موقف اثار حفيظه موسكو
التي لا تزال تلقي بثقلها وراء النظام فقد
اعتبر وزير الخارجيه الروسي سيرجي لافروف
ان الاعتراف يتنافى مع ما تم التوصل اليه
في مؤتمر جنيف بشان الحوار بين الحكومه
والمعارضه لكن المعارضه التي يبدو انها
تشعر بعدم الارتياح تجاه تحفظ القوى
الدوليه المسانده لها فيما يتصل بتزويد ف
المقاتله بالسلاح تدرك ان الوضع على الارض
هو الساحه الحقيقيه للمواجهه وليس اروقه
المؤتمرات من هنا جاءت دعوه الائتلاف
للطائفه العلويه بالعصيان المدني ضد
النظام دعوه انطلقت من شعار ترفعه
المعارضه وهو ان كل الطوائف السوريه تتعرض
لظلم النظام ومع اشتداد معاناه السوريين
تشعر المعارضه بمسي الحاجه الى حسم صراع
ثم من يرى انه طال
كثيرا لمنا ش هذا الموضوع معنا في
الاستديو عمر ادلبي ممثل لجان التنسيق
المحليه في سوريا من لندن بروفيسور فواز
جورجز رئيس مركز دراسات الشرق الاوسط في
جامعه لندن ومن مراكش الدكتور وائل ميرزا
مستشار رئيس الائتلاف الوطني لقوى الثوره
والمعارضه السوريه دكتور ابدا معك ما الذي
سيترتب على دفعه الاعتراف هذه هذه
المره في الحقيقه نحن امل ان يكون هذا
المؤتمر نقله حقيقيه في مساله وقوف النظام
الدولي مع الثوره السوريه تحديدا و تاديته
لمهامه ومسؤولياته الاخلاقيه والسياسيه ا
اجماع اكثر من 114 دوله على حق الشعب
السوري في الدفاع عن نفسه له مقتضيات
عمليه حتى الان كان هناك اعتذار او
يعني يعني نوع من التبرير للتقصير في هذا
الامر من خلال لعدم وحده المعارضه
السياسيه ومن خلال ما يمكن القول انه
الخوف من وصول الاسلحه الى ايدي غير
معروفه نحن لدينا الان انجاز حص في خلال
الاشهر الاسابيع القليله الماضيه الاول هو
قيام الائتلاف الوطني لقوى الثوره
والمعارضه السوريه والذي اعترف الجميع
بانه يمثل الشعب السوري بشكل شرعي
والانجاز الاخر في الحقيقه هذا مهم جدا هو
ايضا تشكيل قياده عسكريه مشتركه في الداخل
تضم الغال العظمى من اطياف الجيش الحر ومن
المجالس العسكريه والكتائب الموجوده فنحن
نامل الان الحقيقه ان يكون هناك نقله
نوعيه بناء على تحقيق هذه المطالب
والاجابه على هذه التساؤلات التي كانت
مطروحه سابقا ونرى ان فيما قاله كل
من سمو وزير الخارجيه السعودي
و فخامه سمو رئيس الوزراء القطري الحقيقه
اشاره صريحه الى هذا الامر لانه هما قالا
ما معناه ان الاسباب التي كانت تدعو الى
تردد النظام الدولي في دعم المعارضه بجميع
الاساليب والوسائل تم تجاوزه الان بهذا
الواقع الجديد بروفيسور جرجس هل ينفع
الاعتراف بدون
تسليح الاعتراف مهم جدا جدا جدا الحقيقه
يشكل نقله نوعيه على كل المستويات سياسيا
ودبلوماسيا
ورمزيا ايضا يشير الى تغيير المعادله
الدوليه في الصراع المحتدم في سوريا وايضا
يشير الى العزله الدوليه للقياده السوريه
114 دوله بما فيها الولايات المتحده
والقوى الاوروبيه
وقوى دوليه مهمه جدا هناك شبه قناعه بدات
تتشكل بان الخروج من هذا المازق يتطلب
تنحي الرئيس السوري عن السلطه واشار
التقرير الاخير ل الجلسه اليوم الى هذه
النقطه الاهم من ذلك انا اعتقد ان هناك
شبه اجماع بدا يتشكل في الغرب وخاصه
الولايات المتحده من ان معركه الحسم في
سوريا قد بدات وان الازمه السوريه في
بدايه نهايتها وان هذا الاجتماع يشكل طبعا
يعني نقله نوعيه في هذا الاطار دعني
الحقيقه اشدد على نقطه السلاح وتريس الدول
الغربيه والولايات المتحده في تسليح
المعارضه السوريه سببين رئيسيين قراءت لل
المواقف الاوروبيه والامريكيه هم سيحاولون
استخدام هذا الاعتراف الدولي لتحقيق
اختراق سياسي الهدف الرئيسي للقياده
الامريكيه والقيادات الاوروبيه ليس احداث
اختراق ميداني ولكن اختراق سياسي من خلال
اقناع القياده الروسيه بان لان تضغط على
الرئيس السوري التنحي عن السلطه والبدء في
عمليه التغيير السياسي في سوريا والنقطه
الثانيه في هذا المجال الحقيقه ايضا الضغط
على الحلقه المقربه من الرئيس السوري
للقبول بالامر الواقع قضيه النقطه الثالثه
في هذا المجال ايضا تسليح المعارضه
السوريه هناك تخوف حقيقي كما قال الدكتور
من ان اعطاء السلاح توريد السلاح الى
سوريا يمكن ان يقع في ايادي الخاطئه ومن
هنا محاوله التريس مع انني اعتقد ان اذا
ان القياده الروسيه لم تغير موقفها في
الاسبوعين الاسابيع القادمه انا اعتقد ان
يعني القيادات الاوروبيه والامريكيه يمكن
ان تبدا مرحله ثانيه ونهائيه من محا في
محاوله لاعطاء السلاح للمعارضه السعوديه
ولكن لافروف اعطى موقفه اليوم ممتعض من
اعتراف امريكا بال الائتلاف وايضا فرنسا
شددت على انها لن تسلح حتى
اللحظه طبعا طبعا مرحليا انا في هذا الوقت
الحقيقه هو هناك يعني وزير الخارجيه
الفرنسي قال قررنا
التريس الولايات المتحده ما تزال تتريس
النقطه الاخرى الحقيقه التي اريد التجديد
عليها وطبعا
ضيفك يعرفون اكثر مني في هذا المجال هناك
رؤيتين في الدول الاوروبيه امريكيه ازاء
الائتلاف الوطني رؤيه تقول بان الائتلاف
الوطني نجح الى حد كبير في هذه الفتره
القصيره في بناء الحقيقه في التعامل
والتواصل مع القوى الداخليه في سوريا
القوى العسكريه والمحليه والرؤيه الاخرى
تقول بان بان المعارضه في الداخل وخاصه
الاجنحه المسلحه هي الحقيه لديها اليد
العليا و ومن هنا قضيه التريس في تسليح
المعارضه لان ليس هناك من قناعه في الدول
الاوروبيه والامريكيه من ان الائتلاف
الوطني هو الحقيقه لديه اليد الاولى
والعليا في الصراع المحتدم في سوريا
داخليا ا استاذ عمر اد البي دعني اتوقف
معك عند نقطه دعوه مععد الخطيب للعلويين
للانضمام الى الثوره وا اعلان العصيان
المدني ولكن ليست هنالك شخصيات بارزه جدا
علويه انضمت للثوره منذ بداياتها وحتى
عانت في مراحل ما قبل الثوره من غياهب جون
نعم بالتاكيد هناك العديد من الشخصيات
المعارضه من الطائفه العلويه شاركت في هذه
الثوره وهناك حراك ثوري من الشباب
العلويين ساهموا معنا منذ بدايه هذه
الثوره وحتى هذه اللحظه هذا الحراك لم
ينقطع على الاطلاق ولكنه ليس بال يعني
بالكثافه المطلوبه فعلا لكي نقول ان هناك
يعني عدد كبير من الطائفه العلويه قد تخلت
عن دعم ال النظام هذه النقطه في غايه
الاهميه لان النظام يتكئ على هذه الطائفه
حتى الان ولكن اليست هنالك طوائف اخرى
هنالك مسيحيون لازالوا مع النظام هنالك
دروز هنالك حتى بعض السنه من التجار
وغيرهم لا يزالون يقفون مع النظام لماذا
التشديد على العلويين دون سواهم لان
النظام اعتمد على عدد كبير من الضباط في
الامن وفي قوى القوات المسلحه ل من
الطائفه العلويه المقربه جدا منه من يعني
من عائلته ومن الاصدقاء المقربين له بشكل
خاص هؤلاء لهم سطوه ولهم كلمه ولهم حضور
اجتماعي كبير في اوساط قراهم وفي اوساط
مدنهم لذلك نلاحظ ان هذا التاثير الكبير
لهؤلاء الضباط الكبار في رتبهم والكبار في
تاثيرهم ومسؤولياتهم وسلطاتهم تم يعني
حضورهم قوي في وسطهم الاجتماعي وهذا الوسط
الاجتماعي ما لم يتحرك جديا في دعم الثوره
وفي التخلي عن الظام بشار الاسد فان امد
الازمه ستطول كما طالت حتى الان اكثر من
20 شهرا للاسف دكتور دتور ميرزا بالنسبه
لنقطه الدعوه الى العلويين ولكن عمليا على
الارض هل ترى اي شيء يشجعهم على الانضمام
للثوره مع كل التحريض الذي يمارسه البعض
ضدهم كونهم يقفون مع
النظام الحقيقه لو سمحتي لي فقط ان اعلق
نقطه هامه جدا على على ما قال الدكتور
فواز جورجوس والموضوع ككل ساجيب على على
سؤالك نحن بكل صراحه وشفافيه نراهن اولا
واخيرا فعلا على الثوار في الداخل وعلى ال
الانجازات التي يحققها الجيش الحر ونعلم
با ايضا بصراحه وشفافيه ان هذه الانجازات
وهذا الواقع الذي يخلقه الجيش الحل على
الارض هو الذي يحرك المجتمع الدولي هذا من
ناحيه من ناحيه اخرى برغم احترامنا الشديد
لجميع اصدقاء سوريا لكننا في الحقيقه نرى
ان هذا يشكر نوع من الاطار العام للمشروع
التي تعطى للائتلاف لكننا نراهن بشكل كبير
جدا على اخوتنا في اخوتنا العرب بشكل عام
وبالذات في دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي
وتحديدا اخوتنا في السعوديه وقطر
والامارات واخوتنا في تركيا من هذا
المنطلق الائتلاف قام يعني بت تحركين في
اتجاهين الاول هو توثيق العلاقه مع الداخل
المجالس المحليه الفاعله على الارض هي
مكون رئيسي للائتلاف وهذا من ميزاته
الرئيسيه ايضا حصل هناك اجتماع قياده
الائتلاف حضرت جزء من الاجتماعات توحيد
الكتائب الجيش الحر التي كانت حصلت في
الاسابيع السابقه ولدينا في الحقيقه
اجتماع قادم قريبا بعد عده ايام هناك
لمتابعه التنسيق في هذا الاطار الامر
الاخر ايضا ان لدينا تنسيق كامل مع اخوتنا
الذين نعول عليهم كما ذكرت نحن نعلم ان
الدعم الحقيقي سياتي في النهايه من اخوتنا
كما ذكرت في السعوديه في قطر في الامارات
واخوتنا واشقائه واصدقائنا في تركيه لكن
الاطار العام هو الاطار اصدقاء سوريا فنحن
واقعيون في هذا الاطار ونركز على القوى
الفاعله التي ستصنع الحدث في النهايه هذا
لا يعني ان لا نتحاور وان لا ننفتح على كل
اصدقاء سوريا اجابه سريعه على سؤالك
المحدد بخصوص اخوتنا في الطائفه العلويه
كما ذكرنا اليوم هناك دعوه كانت واضحه من
الاستاذ احمد معاز الخطيب لمد اليد الى
الاخوه في الطائفه العلويه نحن نعلم انهم
الجزء الغالبيه الكبرى منهم عانوا كثيرا
من النظام كما عانت شرائح الشعب باسرها
وانه هناك فئه منتفعه من هذه الطائفه كما
هو الحال مع فئات منتفعه من الطوائف
الاخرى لذلك النظره الموضوعيه الى الامر
ان ان الاوان لبعض الشرائح التي يعني
نستطيع ان نقول انها لم تظهر الى الان
صوتها من الطائفه العلويه ومن الطوائف
الاخرى بما فيها الطائفه السنيه بعد ان
ورت رات هذا الواقع وما وصلنا اليه وادراك
المجتمع الدولي باسره ان هذا النظام اقترب
الى نهايته الوقت الان
سانح لكي تغتنم الفرصه وتقول كلمتها
وتساعدنا ونساعد بعض جميعا ان شاء الله في
حصول عمليه انتقاليه خاليه من اي عنف من
خاليه من اي عمليات انتقاميه وان نخلق
سوريا الجديده السوريا دوله المواطنه
والمشاركه للجميع سوف نواصل النقاش ولكن
بعد فاصل قصير فانتظرونا
[موسيقى]
بعده
اهلا بكم من جديد في حلقتنا التي تتناول
اجتماع مجموعه اصدقاء سوريا في مراكش
دكتور جرجس
باعتقادك بعد وضع جبهه النصره من قبل
الامريكيين على لائحه الارهاب هل هذا يعني
امكانيه تسليح بقيه الفصائل التي لا
تعتبرها واشنطن
ارهابيه انا اعتقد ذلك انا انا اعتقد ان
مساله تسليح المعارضه هو ومساله وقت وخاصه
اذا لم يحدث اختراق سياسي في الصراع
السوري في الاسابيع القادمه
ا يعني وطبعا المعارضه السوريه تحصل على
انواع مهمه من الاسلحه من دول الجوار ولكن
الدول الغربيه والقياده الامريكيه تتريس
لعده اسباب كما ذكرت نقطه مهمه جدا في هذا
الاطار بالنسبه للاستراتيجيه الامريكيه
والغربيه يتخوفون جدا
من ان اطاله عمر النزاع العسكري في سوريا
يمكن ان يدمر الدوله السوريه ويدمر النسيج
الاجتماعي في سوريا ا يعني الهدف الرئيسي
لهذه القيادات منع الحريق السوري من
التهام الاخضر واليابس في سوريا يعني ما ز
ماز القيادات ما يعني عم تفكر كثير انه
الحل السياسي التغيير السياسي هو الحل
الافضل والانجذاب وطبعا نحن نعلم ان
القياده الروسيه حتى الان لم يحدث اي
تغيير جذري في هذا الاطار وايضا تعول
القيادات الغربيه والامريكيه على الحلقه
المقربه من الرئيس السوري وطبعا هذه قضيه
نظريه لانني لا اعتقد ان الحلقه المقربه
من من الرئيس السوري يعني يمكن في هذا
الوقت ان تغير
موقفها يعني تغيير جوهري يؤدي الى اختراق
سياسي ما رايك بقول لافروف ان الامريكيين
يعولون على حسم المعارضه العسكري لهذا
النزاع هل في النهايه سيحسم النزاع عسكريا
وليس سياسيا
باعتقادك يبدو الحقيقه ان كل
الاستراتيجيين في بريطانيا وفرنسا
والولايات المتحده والمانيا يعتقدون بان
المعارضه السوريه قد حققت انجازات تكتيكيه
مهمه على الارض وان هذه الانجازات
التكتيكيه
سوف يعني
تتواصل في الاسابيع القادمه وطبعا بعض
التقارير الاستخباراتيه ويمكن طبعا علينا
ان لا نصدق كل التقارير الاستخباراتيه في
الولايات المتحده تقول ان مساله الحسم هي
مساله ثلاثه او اربع اشهر على الاكثر
لانهم يعتقدون بان القوات السوريه
النظاميه قد انهق يعتقدون بان الوضع
الاقتصادي خطير جدا يعتقدون بان الاجنحه
المعارضه اصبحت اكثر تنظيما وقدره على
التعامل مع الوضع الميداني ولكن ولكن
النقطه الاهم في هذا الاطار على الرغم من
الاعتقاد بان المعارضه لديها القدره على
المدى المنظور لتحقيق اخراق ميداني هم
يفضلون انجازا سياسيا يحفظ الدوله السوريه
ولا يدمر البنى الرئيسيه للدوله السوريه
الخوف الرئيسي في هنا في لندن وفي واشنطن
من ان انجاز اختراق عسكري ميداني يمكن ان
يؤدي الى تدمير الدوله السوريه النسيج
الاجتماعي في سوريا وان يرجح كفه القوى
الراديكاليه مثل ما يسمونه جبهه النصره
النصره والقوى الجهاديه الاخرى كما
يعتقدون دكتور ميرزا ما قولك في هذا الشان
حسم عسكري ام سياسي ومرد على الخشيه من
قوى راديكاليه تسيطر
بعدها
ا ليس هناك ضروره
ل التفكير بهذه الطريقه بهذه
الثنائيه الثوره السوريه الان وصلت الى
مرحله من النضج والنمو بحيث تدرك ان الحسم
يحتاج الى تكامل المسارين المسار السياسي
والمسار
العسكري ابطال الجيش الحر الثوار في
الداخل يفرضون كما ذكرنا امرا واقعا من
اقصى شمال سوريا الى اقصى جنوبها ومن اقصى
الشرق الى اقصى الغرب اي الجيش الحر يحاصر
مطار دمشق الدولي كان متواجد في قلب دمشق
في الصالحيه امس مناطق واسعه نعلم جميعا
محرره في الشمال وفي الشرق و قوات الجيش
الحر تستولي على قواعد جويه وبريه وقواعد
صواريخ وفرق باكملها هذا مسار مستمر ويجب
ان يستمر وهو الذي يضغط حتى نكون واقعيين
هو الذي يضغط على المجتمع الدولي لكي يدرك
ان هذه الثوره ستحقق اهدافها في نفس
الاطار المسار السياسي المسار السياسي
قائم طيب والاعتراف اليوم دليل على ذلك
ولكن السؤال هو الان كيف تردون على مخاوف
من يعني على اي اساس مثلا اليوم مد الخطيب
طلب اعاده النظر بادراج جبهه النصره على
قائمه الارهاب هل انتم لديكم ك ائتلاف خطه
واضحه للتعاطي مع هذه الجماعات التي حاربت
النظام طيب بعد ذلك ولو سقط النظام كيف
سيجري استيعاب هذه الجماعات مع ما تؤمن به
هي لا انا ضعيني اضع الامر في اطاره
الاكبر نحن الان نتصرف كدوله الائتلاف
الوطني السوري يتصرف كدوله
والدول ليس بالضروره تتطابق في كل وجهات
النظر مع بعضها هناك مصالح مشتركه وهناك ح
وارات امريكا اصدرت قرارها ونحن بالنسبه
لنا كما اكد الاستاذ احمد معاذ الخطيب
لدينا وجهه نظر اخرى ونامل ان تعيد النظر
في هذا الاطار نحن نعلم الوضع الداخلي في
سوريا بشكل دقيق جدا ونعلم ان هناك كثير
من الحركات التي تنطلق من الرؤيه
الاسلاميه في حركتها لكن ليست بالضروره ان
تكون متطرفه يعني كما قال فيما
اعتقد العميد سليم ادريس ليس كل من يربي
رحيه هو من القاعده هذه قضيه يجب ان تؤخذ
بعين الاعتبار بعيدا عن التعميمات التي
تطرح هنا وهناك نحن نعتقد انه يعني اي
الجزء الاكبر من الغالبيه العظمى القصوى
من ال الكتائب المقاتله والجيش الحر هي في
الحقيقه وطنيه خالصه وفي نفس الوقت نرجو
انه نلفه النظر الى انه اي هذه الجهات
التي وضعت على ما يسمى بلائحه الارهاب لم
تصدر منها اي
تصرفات عسكريه او امنيه ضد رعايا اجانب ضد
دول خارجيه فهناك مقاييس معينه قانونيه
دوليه يجب ان تؤخذ بعين الاعتبار ونحن
نتشاور ونتشاور مع الامريكان وم غيرهم في
هذا الاطار لكي نضعها في اطارت لكن دكتور
جبهه النصره منذ عام 2011 زعيمها موضوع
على قائمه الارهاب ومرتبط بتنظيم القاعده
في
العراق
يا سيدتي في الحقيقه قضيه الممارسات هي
التي تجعلنا نحكم في النهايه يعني انا لست
محاميا لكن القانونيين والمحامين ومن
يعملون في هذا الاطار ينظرون الى
الممارسات هناك نحن نرى على ارض الواقع ان
هناك مجموعات
موجوده اذا من يكن نحن نرفض تماما
اي طريقه في التفكير تملي على اي شريحه من
الشعب سوري اي املاءات معينه عقائديه او
سياسيه نرفضها تماما وسنتعامل معها
قانونيا ودستوريا واجتماعيا وثقافيا لكن
فيما عدا ذلك نريد ان نرى وجود اي ممارسات
اذا وجدنا فعلا ممارسات تندرج تحت اطار
قانوني انها فعلا يمكن ان تسبب ان يوضع اي
احد في خانه الارهاب فنحن منفتحون على هذا
الامر لمناقشته ولمسا عده يعني ما يجب ان
يحصل في هذا شكرا لك سيد عمر ادلبي اخيرا
انت ممثل لجان تنسيق محليه في سوريا انت
مطلع على ما يجري على الارض في سوريا هل
تعتقد ان الناس العدين الشعب السوري ككل ب
شرائحه المختلفه مرتاح الى الحراك السياسي
الذي يجري واعتراف اكثر من 114 دوله بهذا
الائتلاف وتعتقد انه على الارض مرتاح لذلك
يعني منذ انطلاق الائتلاف منذ الاعلان عن
الائتلاف بدا ان هناك ارتياح كبير في
الشارع السوري لهذا الانجاز السياسي
الخطوات الت التي تلت ذلك ولا سما الاشراف
من قبل الائتلاف الوطني السوري على توحيد
الكتائب المسلحه وكتائب الثوار كان ايضا
هناك يعني رافقه ارتياح اكبر من الشارع
السوري اليوم مع هذا الانجاز السياسي
الكبير على صعيد التمثيل السياسي لهذا
الائتلاف للشعب السوري كممثل وحيد هو
بالتاكيد ايضا مرتاح ما ينتظره الشعب
السوري الان هو اجراءات عمليه تساعد
الائتلاف فعليا على تقديم المساعده
للمدنيين السوريين الذين يعانون معاناه
شديده جدا ينتظرون ايضا السوريين ان يقدم
هذا الائتلاف ان يقدم لهذا الائتلاف
ممكنات دعمه لكتائب الثوار المسلحه
ليستطيعوا فعليا حمايه المدنيين من جهه
وتحقيق اهداف الثوره ولا سيما على صعيد
اسقاط النظام شكرا جزيلا لك عمر ادلبي
ممثل لجن التنسيق المحليه في سوريا ايضا
اشكر من لندن بروفيسور فواز جرجس رئيس
مركز دراسات الشرق الاوسط في جامعه لندن
وايضا اشكرك دكتور وائل مرزى مستشار رئيس
الائتلاف الوطني لقوى الثوره والمعارضه
السوريه حدثتنا من مراكش واشكر متابعتكم
بهذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء
الخبر نلتقي باذن الله في قراءه جديده
فيما وراء خبر جديد الى
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اللقاء